I reached this place five minutes after
the earthquake it's like the Eiffel
Tower or let's say a statue of liberty
you know no one can imagine losing those
things I couldn't come back here
especially when I heard that my friend
died with her sister and mother in law
the night we survive we made a phone
call to almost every friends I knew in
my circle so we loaned about 3,700 US
dollars and we got into action we did
the food distribution like Oh from the
third date it's not about this year it's
not about one month you poured in some
help and provided some food and tents
and that the people are in good shape
we've lost many things I want you to
come down here and see on the ground
level we have lost many things which
would take about maybe five to ten years
to reconstruct so help people out we are
trying to reconstruct our country help
be country out to get from the hard
times we are looking at a long long
period of time so we need help
you